hey guys it's justine and a huge thank
you to apple for partnering with me on
today's video we are getting hands on
with the new oppo find x5 pro and i am
so excited to check this out because as
you guys know i'm a huge fan of mobile
photography and especially video they
really stepped up their game with their
new npu mari silicone x chip to power
real-time raw processing and hdr video
so i am so ready to test out some photos
and videos on this thing but first we've
gotta open it up
let's
go okay i thought it was gonna be right
there but it's not we have one more
layer the suspense
[Music]
oh look at this look at this look at
this
look at you
oh
my goodness
okay i'm so hyped about this because
this is actually a ceramic back phone
and i'm such a huge fan of ceramic
this looks
so
sleek like the way that they gradually
did this camera bump like it's very
smooth like this feels like a futuristic
spaceship check that out
i love the color i love the shine also
i'm always so concerned when i get a
device like this that it instantly will
start smudging with this ceramic um
yeah
we love
to see that or not see it because
there's no fingerprints it's not leaving
any smudges let's see what else is in
the box we have oh a power brick what a
treat that is
and we have our usb
c cable to charge
also a treat
and in here
oh we have a case love that freaking
this is key especially when i'm gonna
take this thing out and start testing it
i don't trust myself sim card ejector
also love that it's this
premium service exclusive benefits
because i deserve it thank you
let's get this thing powered on and
start testing
the new oppo find x5 pro features a
snapdragon 8 gen 1 processor for 30 more
performance and 25 more power efficiency
it features a multi-tier cooling system
that has a vapor chamber to keep the
device cool under high intensity
workloads like gaming ai frame rate
stabilization will also help control the
temperature while keeping the game
running as smooth as possible this is a
5 000 milliamp hour dual cell battery
which is the first smartphone to feature
oppo's new smart charging technology
battery health engine the number of
charging cycles has been doubled to 1600
giving this battery two times the
lifespan compared to the industry
standard it even has reverse wireless
charging in case you need to share your
battery with a friend in need i also
can't get over this really cool design
this ceramic backing is just incredible
it makes it feel really futuristic and
sleek the display is a 6.7 inch amoled
with 120 hertz dynamic refresh rates and
it looks really incredible when you're
gaming or watching content let's talk
about the cameras because that is one of
my favorite things to test out this
features a 50 megapixel wide camera with
a 110 degree field of view there's a 50
megapixel wide camera and a 13 megapixel
telephoto camera these are using sony's
imx 766 sensors which is allowing you to
capture 10-bit video recording with up
to 1 billion colors image stabilization
is so important when it comes to
handheld devices and this has a first of
its kind five axis optical image
stabilization with a three axis sensor
shift and two axis lens shift and three
degree anti-shake so uh what does that
mean that means way less shaky videos
and blurry photos and i am so here for
that apple partnered with hasselblad to
bring natural color calibration to your
photos there's a 13 channel spectral
sensor that is located right here and
that will more accurately detect a
scene's color spectrum so the camera can
better reproduce natural skin tones and
colors they also collaborated with
top-tier hasselblad photographers to
develop a range of master filters and
these will instantly give your photos a
professional color profile since we're
on the topic of photography we can't
forget selfies there is a front-facing
32 megapixel camera that is using the
sony imx 709 sensor to capture 60 more
light and with the new mari silicone x
chip it is able to process photos more
accurately in challenging lighting
conditions oh also if more than one
person joins the frame it'll
automatically switch from 80 to 90
degrees so none of your friends will be
left out of the shot unless of course
you want them left out of the shot then
you can just crop them out later
something that i really like about this
phone is it also has a log feature so
when i turn that on i will be able to
get greater control over the brightness
the colors i can actually color grade it
how i want to color it you can always
color grade non-log footage with the
fact that this is an option and i can
turn that on i'm gonna try it out look
at this stuff isn't it neat this is all
shot not in log now i'm gonna switch it
to log so you can see the difference
that all of the color is very
desaturated and that gives us a lot more
flexibility to make this any of the
colors that we want i also like in these
pro modes i can adjust the aperture the
iso so this definitely gives you a lot
more flexibility if you're in some very
harsh lighting conditions like today ooh
we're outside testing out the new phone
i'm so excited jenna's back there
filming for me so we're gonna take some
photos we're gonna make some videos and
see how it looks honestly holding this
phone in my hand and just the ceramic
back of this thing is so beautiful
like i just want to show everyone here
but i can't show them yet because
technically this phone isn't out yet
oh yeah macro mode we're so close to
this tree i can see
i can see your beginnings i love this ai
mode it says i'm taking pictures of
green plants and you know what i'm doing
i'm taking pictures
[Music]
this is goal video view
this is great i really like this because
if i want to get my reaction to
something happening
[Music]
just what do you can you do the run
through the the ultra wide the y the
telephoto what do we got jen what's
first okay so as you're seeing here is
ultra wide
i mean i'm in the bushes
so this is one x this is the wide camera
am i solar bushes oh yeah okay cool
what happens if we zoom in will i be out
of the bushes kinda but not really okay
yeah we love that zoom just you know you
are in the shade though
yeah cause i'm under a tree
[Music]
so there's also a really cool feature
that has the ultra steady pro and when
you put this on it does have to crop in
it switches it to 60 frames a second and
it does drop it down to 1080 but this
will allow you to get some really super
steady shots so even though this is 1080
a lot of times when you're mixing this
in with youtube videos because of
compression rates and if you're just
sending things to your friends and
family the fact that this is downgraded
to 1080 is really not a big deal at all
especially if it's super steady
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching this
was so fun getting a chance to unbox
this and give you guys some of my first
impressions i'm going to be posting some
photos on my instagram and on my twitter
if you guys want to check out some of
the night features i look forward to
testing this out more and if you guys
have any questions feel free to leave
them in the comments below thank you
guys again for watching i'll see you in
the next one bye
[Music]
walking around
now you see me
now you still see me
film
some feet action
[Music]